we keep hearing that critical race
theory isn't being taught in schools
this is what we heard in virginia this
is the case that terry mcauliffe makes
this is what the media keeps saying
critical race theory
they sometimes sometimes they say it
doesn't exist it's a it's a boogeyman
invented
uh by the right
which is which is a problem because
there have been actual books written
with critical race theory in the title
by the people who came up with this
theory and are promoting it
but even if it exists what we're told is
it's not taught in schools
and the thing is
that's true
in a certain way
it's true but it's sometimes you can lie
while telling the truth
you could tell the truth in a way that
is intentionally misleading and here we
have a public school teacher in indiana
explaining what it really means when
they say the critical race theory isn't
taught in schools let's listen to that
i'm the science coach in admin in the
largest public school district in
indiana i'm in dozens of classrooms a
week so i see exactly what we're
teaching our students when we tell you
that schools aren't teaching critical
race theory that it's nowhere in our
standards that's misdirection we don't
have the quotes and theories as state
standards per se we do have critical
race theory in how we teach we tell our
teachers to treat students differently
based on color we tell our students that
every problem is a result of white men
and that everything western civilization
built as racist capitalism as a tool of
white supremacy those are straight out
of kimberly crenshaw's main points
verbatim in critical race theory the
writings that formed the movement
this is in math history science english
the arts and it's not slowing down if
students of color have lower reading
scores it's because of inequity
therefore we take from the white
students and give to the color students
that's richard delgado straight out of
crt and introduction
all teaching is political with reality
and facts taking the back seat that's dr
gloria lads and billings who outlined
how she saw critical race theory fleshed
out in public schools in 1995.
when schools tell you that we aren't
teaching critical race theory it means
one thing go away and look into our
affairs no further it isn't about
transparency it isn't about cultural
relevance it's race essentialism painted
to look like the district cares about
students of color we call it anti-racism
so you feel bad if you disagree with our
segregationist pedagogy it's taking
advantage of kids vulnerability and
parents inactivity to preen over social
snake oil schemes designed to create
division
parents when we tell you critical race
theory isn't taught in our schools we're
lying keep looking
well he lays it out right there um and
that's
like it's just like if if uh if they
claim you know when we say that
the public schools are leftist and that
there's leftism you know in the broadest
sense in the public school system
well they could say well we don't teach
leftism look at our curriculum nowhere
does it say the the term leftist or
leftism
uh you silly parents why you think your
kid is going to a leftism 101 class
no that's obviously not what's happening
in fact i wouldn't object to that
necessarily i mean in theory i wouldn't
object to that
having a class on the subject of modern
day leftism i wouldn't even necessarily
in theory object to a class on critical
race theory because i think it is
something that unfortunately our kids
need to know about now i wouldn't trust
the average public school teacher to
teach it
but kids are going to get to a certain
age where you do have to teach them
about this
it's a good thing to teach them about it
about the subject
just like they should learn about
marxism and communism
you want them to learn about those
things
it's the people who are
trying to indoctrinate kids into these
worldviews that don't want the kids
taught about the worldview
and that should tell you what you need
to know
but that's not what's happening so
treating
treating these things as a subject and
saying here's this
worldview that exists here's this idea
this system of thought
uh here's what it what it teaches
there you go presenting the information
that could be a good thing
i mean all all of the most insidious
world views
the wider spread that they are the the
more that i think we need to uh
it's good for us to know what they are
and be taught about them
but that's not what's happening what's
happening is much much worse than that
as the teacher just explained
instead it's the assumptions of critical
race theory are embedded
into everything the kids are taught
so this is a big
you know this is a this is a red herring
this is misdirection
it's the sleight of hand trick where
they you know they hand you the
curriculum
and they say see look at the curriculum
you'll see nowhere on this curriculum
does it say critical race theory yeah
it's not being taught
what they fail to mention is that in
every single one of those subjects on
that curriculum
all of those subjects are built around
and upon this the assumptions of
critical race theory
that
white people are inherently racist
that um all of our historical
ills and all the historical evils are
all the result of of white people and
western expansion
um that it's you know it's not even
possible to be racist against
white people because racism equals
is whatever prejudice plus power
kids are taught all of that where else
are they getting this stuff from
yeah they're getting it from the media
they're getting it from
social media from the internet but um
you're getting it from a lot of places
but they're certainly getting it from
the schools
as well
and the fact that they are told these
things
and yet are not told
that this is critical race theory that's
precisely the problem
again i would have no i think i would
have no problem in theory
with a kid being told hey there's this
thing called critical race theory and
according to critical race theory what
the critical race theory teaches
is that if you're white you're
inherently racist
and that if a black person comes up to
you
and says they hate you because you're
white
you are not a victim of racism because
they can't be racist against you
that's what critical race theory teaches
that's a good thing for people to be
told because then they can say oh well
okay well that so that's a theory i
don't ascribe to it sounds like a pretty
horrible theory
remember the word theory you know
it's also important to remember
the word theory when used in a
scientific context it doesn't just mean
a you know a hypothesis or a guess
a theory uh like the the quote-unquote
theory of gravity right
it's a system
for explaining
what you see in the physical world
that's what a theory is in science
uh we talk about the theory of evolution
right or you know
the germ theory of disease it's a system
for explaining and understanding what
you're observing in the physical world
critical race theory
positions itself as that kind as a
theory in that way it's a system
of explaining and understanding what we
not what we see in the physical world
but what we what we see in human society
[Music]
but it's a bad system
it's a it's an evil system
it's a sinister system hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated